we're super excited about our next guest
he's knockout academy award winner
matthew mcconaughey
he's holding a virtual benefit to help
his home state of texas
after was devastated by last month's
massive winter storm you know the one
so this sunday mcconaughey and his
gorgeous wife camilla are hosting where
texas
it will feature performances from an
all-star lineup including
listen to his roster casey musgraves
kelly clarkson willie nelson
just to name a few the mcconaughey's
just keep livin foundation created a
texas relief fund
after the storm left some four million
people without power
and nearly 15 million people without
clean water wow
their foundation will use all the
proceeds from the benefit concert to
help the
lone star state rebuild and assist
people who are still struggling
to get food water and shelter that
continues today matthew joins us now
from his home in austin texas good to
see you matthew
good morning uh good to see y'all good
morning
this is the thing you have to help us
understand about texas
i don't care if people were born there
lived there for two years
passed through texas anybody associates
with texas wants you to know i'm from
texas
i don't hear that about any other states
i'm from maryland
i don't see people going maryland or
idaho i'm not knocking any other states
but there does seem to me
something about texas what is the allure
of texas and the people that live
and are born a pride we do have pride of
plenty
yeah um you know you're raised as a
texan you are expected
to act a certain way because you're a
texan if you get out of line
people will remind you let you know
that's not tech i love you
um so some of us are born here um some
of us move here as quick as we can
some others like my wife camilla married
in and is now a texan some people just
come for the barbecue but you come here
for any amount of time listen matthew it
seems to stay in your heart
how hard was it for you to convince
people who did you call what did you do
what was your pit well
this was beautiful and this is a
beautiful thing about about texans as
well it didn't take long at all to
convince people so as soon as camilla
and i
said okay something needs to be done
what do we need to do we came with the
idea of the benefit i call
salesforce i called dell technologies
they call reliant energy bam they come
in with big founding sponsorships right
off the bat
then i get on the phone and then 30
seconds every performer
every texas business every sports star
is like yes what do you need me to do
tell me when and where i'm in
that was the easy part um we got getting
the whole production together as you
know when these things happen
they're timely because you don't want to
be too far away from
the disaster when the needs are there
which the needs are on the ground right
now
at the same time you want to put
together a good show so we're happy with
where we are
with a lot of help from a lot of people
in texas and beyond
what do you see as the biggest need on
the ground right now matthew
well it's water damage you know when the
power went out that was a heavy duty
inconvenience but
that was a trickle-down effect the the
no heat
from no power leads to frozen pipes
leads to burst pipes
leads to water damage and water damage
is sort of the silent killer it's not
what you see
from the street you don't see that
devastation when you're driving down the
street but you go in these front doors
and that's what you see you see roofs
caved in you see
places that are unlivable you see
furniture that's no longer
possible to use you see mattresses that
are done so it's what the water damage
has done
that has allowed a lot of people not
even to be able disallow people to even
be able to live in their homes now
yeah hey matthew during the height of
the pandemic you put out several psas
encouraging people to stay home
encouraging people to wear a mask now
the governor of texas is lifting
restrictions including the mask mandate
what's your reaction to that thank you
for asking me that
i reacted that is i'm gonna go back to
that
word i think i'd you know alluded to a
minute ago i was a little uh
dumbfounded by the decision i understand
go back to work
what i did not understand was pull the
mask mandate
i look it's it's it's uh we're on our
way
to seeing light at the end of the tunnel
to pull it the mask
is just this minor inconvenience and and
i think i just want to remind
not only texans but everybody out there
from my opinion it's not the mask
we're afraid of come on it's the word
mandate yeah
all right so let's not let the word
mandate get in the way of the practical
use of this little tool called a mask
but hey it's just a small inconvenience
today for more freedom
tomorrow so now it's our choice all
right so now and i and i ask uh texans
and
people around the world it's our choice
if you have the choice
keep masking up it's proven to help we
don't have much longer in this
we'll get through this thank you you
know
this is the thing the scientists always
tell you the mask work but this is the
thing matthew mcconaughey is it possible
at this time to speak to potential
gubernatorial candidate
governor mcconaughey is he there he's
he's
he's not here right now
let me look around for him this is
matthew mcconaughey actor and author and
father of three
and man who along with his wife camilla
is in a whole lot of other help is
putting on this benefit
it does seem to keep coming up matthew
it does seem to keep coming up at some
point you're going to have to
yeah are you giving it any consideration
yeah as i've said before i'm giving it
consideration i would be a fool not to
it's it's a very honorable thing to
consider you know what that position
would mean what would it be for me what
it mean for the people of texas
um and as i've said before and i'll say
again right now i have to decide for me
what is my category where i can be most
useful
in life from here well matthew yeah but
right now we know what that is yeah and
it does occur to me that there might be
potential on the senate side of things
as well after
senator cruz the great state of texas
fled the state of texas for
the country of mexico cancun to be exact
uh
what'd you make of that now you're
getting to the funny questions
i'm i'm not taking the bait on that one
that one's more like
that's that's more like page six gossip
stuff to me
but the real meat on the ground what do
we got to do
now that got that but that got that got
taken out of out of
different proportions and i wasn't there
enough that's talking about where
somebody was at what time
and then memes got going and t-shirts
got going i'm not jumping on that
bandwagon but matthew
how about this how about this you've
made it no secret listen you and your
family have been very blessed you've
done
okay during this pandemic but this
clearly matters to you what is happening
in texas
it almost seems like a purpose for you
is it not
well it is a purpose that's what happens
when certain
disasters come i mean purpose takes the
capital p
and you know i need to go into action
this was camilla who came to me
actually i had my head down in a project
that i was working on and camilla came
and knocked on
my door and said do you see what's
happening yeah here
and i was like yeah it's fatty she goes
no it's real bad we got to do something
and so you know she has my back i put my
head down gathered people to go to work
i've got a huge team that came together
immediately as i spoke of that's good
um and and now on you know march 21st
7 p.m central texas time i'm going to be
here to dj and host the show you're
going to see all those amazing musical
acts that we've got
coming in that gave their entertainment
for free many texans and businesses came
and put their donations and money out
for
for for free at no cost to us well i'll
just say this
if matthew mcconaughey called me i'd
pick up the phone too thank you
we're really looking forward to the 21st
cheering you on
always always thank you bye-bye you can
donate to word texas on matthew's
youtube page
and watch the benefit concert there this
sunday at 8 00
eastern seven central five pacific